what happened is I found that I needed
to write down my criteria and test them
so I started with in the markets because
I I you know it's tough to wrestle all
in your head with everything and so I
found that I needed to do that and I
could test the criteria and I found that
transformative because one I could test
them I know how they would have worked I
test the logic when I tested them I
learned in ways that I wouldn't have
learned and then I could systemize the
decision making I could write them into
equations I could have the computer help
me I could be understood by people I was
with we could debate the criteria rather
than just screaming our conclusions at
each other and that then led me to do
the same thing in when I'm managing the
company okay I have a company it grows
you know from
9 to 1500 people and you know how do we
communicate how we do it how do you have
an idea of meritocracy how do you do
that so writing down my criteria and the
principles and then saying should we
debate that is that the right way